dated November 12th 1963 from JFK to the
CIA where he's asking for information
about UFOs from the CIA 10 years before
his death can somebody please somebody
can John Greenwald can you focus on
falsifying that like or or corroborating
it or you know whatever let's let's like
get close to the truth on that and it's
just it's weird how much information is
just sort of sitting there in this like
gray area state where it feels like I
have to do like a V vigilante job where
it's like UFO Reporting is the crime and
I'm sort of a bystandard not super well
equipped to to you know make sure the
crime doesn't happen but it's like I
feel I feel Duty and then and then I I
don't feel like I'm best equipped to do
some of this stuff where some of these
documents are just lying there in this
like sort of you know Lial space and we
should we should we should we should
falsify or corroborate them